um who is an informatics postdoctoral
researcher at Oregon clinical
translational Research Institute or oak
tree
he earned his PhD in Masters in computer
science from Marquette University in
2022. his research focuses on
data-driven casual casual explorations
of bioinformatics to improve public
health health informatics and overall
health care research one of his primary
research interests lies in causal
inference and with the intent to apply
related theories in exploring cause and
effect relationships in experimental and
observational Healthcare data sets
is broader research interests include
statistical modeling machine learning
Data Mining bioinformatics and data
science he will be presenting his talk
today drawing causality from
observational data in health care
approaches to causal modeling and
reasoning through graphical
models thank you so deep it's all yours
or she interpreted reassurance that she
had other classes I think she was
seems like we're getting some um talk in
the background
I think it's all good now right
all right
um
hello everyone
um hi my name is
and I will be talking about one of the
research uh research topic that I've
been purchasing for a couple of years
which is drawing causality from
observational data in healthcare and I
will be going through approaches to
causal modeling and reasoning through
graphical causal models and thank you
all for joining this morning
um I am sorry I could not be there in
person but I'll try to be as informative
as I can be from my remote position
so to give an overview I will be going
through four sections which is I'll
first talk about the motivation for
causal search in healthcare then I will
go in details of theories of causal
inference specifically in healthcare we
will be focusing on structural theory of
causation then I will briefly go over
two of the applied research that we did
which is the causal and transportation
patients in the ICU and also causal
inference for patients receiving
invasive mechanical ventilation at the
ICU I will end my talk today with a
summary and open research problems that
we find generally in causal inference
research domain for healthcare
so the first part is pretty
straightforward like why are we going
for causal inference or causal search in
uh bioinformatics or Healthcare research
domain now the search for causality is
basically at the core of Science and
Discovery and this is
uh this is very
popular or this is very much sought
after in epidemiology social science
economics finance and many other
branches of Sciences
now the standard for finding causal
relationships are generally to go places
to our city like the randomized control
trials
um I'm pretty sure most of you already
know about this stuff but I'll just try
to give a version of myself that I think
of in my head so randomized control
trials are very much
very much in place uh for finding causal
relationship uh the general Pros are
they're very great in finding unbiased
causal effects they are very
statistically reliable and they are very
much comparable in between two studies
but the problem is that
sometimes they're expensive based on
cost time and Manpower and sometimes
they're just invisible so we cannot just
try a new drug in human subjects
sometimes they're just unethical so
there is always a search for finding an
alternative to randomized control trials
that is where the big data comes into
play so right now in our world we have
lots of experimental data so data
collected from different experiments as
well as observational data that is
collected through EHR so like like the
OG OHSU database that we have or the
apic or Cerner so these are kind of a
version of natural experiments so people
interact with different things and we
collect those data these are regularly
curated and analyzed they can be used to
simulate and automatic randomized
content trial and to do that we will
look for causal inference methodologies
so that we can find the causal mechanism
and effect
now how do we end up in a randomized
controller setting so for example let's
say I'm a person and I want I have
current I currently have headache and I
want to know whether taking an aspirin
will relieve me a bit of that headache
or not so that is a normal scenario that
people try to look for
now I can take an aspirin and see how it
works but it does not help me carry that
information for the next time I'm trying
to having that as being or not or
suggesting my friend so what we can do
is we try to do an experiment where we
have a bunch of people taking the drug
and see what the outcome is so that's
the gist of clinical experiments the
goal is to find causal effect but this
is not seem as simple as it looks
because the population might have some
specific features that changes the
outcome based on this treatment
so what we try to do we have a treatment
group and a control group we get two
population set we give the test drag or
the treatment in one group and some kind
of placebo or some other drug another
group and see how the outcome looks so
this is kind of comparison between two
groups but again the population group
might be different so to control for
that we resort to randomization where we
randomly try to match two population
groups where we have similar kind of
population in each set then give the
control and then see the outcome so
that's kind of the gist of the
randomized control trial now you can
already see that this is a very much
manual process like people need to be
involved at every stage and see how the
outcome turns out and how that study is
being taken care of this is really hard
and also expensive
so we are trying to simulate randomized
control trial data from observational
data
in nature experimental data and
observation data are different like in
experimental data we collect data from
Intervention where we take some action
and that changes the outcome
so that is basically reflecting an
effect of an action it it has been
collected with a goal and there is
generally expensive and pure available
in terms of expenditure because these
are expensive to do
now these are very much suited for
causal inference because we can just
directly infer causality from a
randomized control trial versus when we
have observational data this is just
data collected for observation it does
not contain any specific effect it is
just collected as it is found
these are much cheaper to collect faster
to access and more available
but the problem is they're mostly
unexplored there have been noisy and
missing data and they're just suited for
General observation it's not very good
for color inference
let me give you an example how it looks
so let's say we do a new drug study
which is a that's a new drug trial on
men and women and this is an
experimental data set that we have
so in this population group
within the main population subgroup it
seems like 93 percent recovered with
this drug
for the women 73 recovered with the drug
but when we combine these two data sets
it seems like 83 percent recovered with
no drug so you can see the total
percentage changes when we sum up all
these population subsets
now the question is is this drug based
on this trial good or bad like effective
or not
should we prescribe this drug given we
do not know the sex of the person or we
know the sex of the person it looks a
little bit confusing now this is a
well-known Paradox as a group part of
you already know that this is known as
Simpsons products and this has been
found in previous cases as UC Berkeley
gender bass case in 1973 or in kidney
stone treatment case in 1986.
this can be easily mitigated if we look
for a causal inference methodology from
other shell data set and I will go into
that in in later part of my talk
so why do we need causal models
um causal models would represent the
mechanism in which the data is generated
and Ill Healthcare data the features
that we look for like the blood pressure
or some other demographic information
they're not basically mutually
independent they are very much dependent
and causally Tangled so we need to know
what variable is changing the other
variable and we need this causal model
to understand the effects now when we
talk about take our talk about causal
model what are we actually referring to
so this is a simplistic example of a
causal model where for the previous
example that I just gave here
this study
it can be represented in this format
where we can see that the drug is having
an causal effect on the recovery and six
it has an um impact on selecting the
drug as well as the recovery so
basically what we're saying is that this
sex is working as a confounding variable
or a lurking variable that influences
both dependent and independent variable
and it basically is creating a fake
Association and this impact is
represented by treatment decision
trained a favoring drug for women over
men if you look at this data you would
see that more men are not getting the
drug like 270 percent versus 263 women
got the drug so there is a bias based on
the drug suggestion
so
causal models are really helpful in
understanding the causal mechanism or
the motion that triggers in between
variables like if I have an habit of
being late to meetings I can change that
by trying to hurrying up now this is a
very simplistic author model with two
variables and sometimes it's very hard
to associate which one is causing the
other one like is it really being led
that is making people to hurry up or the
other way around and it's really hard to
do so from just two variables but we can
do that if we have more data and more
information on on the overall scenario
this is an example of a collider case in
causal graph where for a school
scholarship you might be looking for
musical talent and sports talent and
they are both
affecting the scholarship of the school
Schools students now this is also
helpful in understanding some other kind
of biases such as selection bias if we
look at a student who got the
scholarship at the school and if we see
that that person has no musical Talent
whatsoever it's very easy to assume that
that person probably has Sports talents
since they already got the scholarship
so what we can see here if we kind of
select on a scholarship then there is a
fake Association created between musical
talent and sports Talent so if you do a
study based on only the peoples in this
school we would say that people who have
musical Talent does not have sports
Talent or vice versa which might not be
really true in real life world so that
is also explained through causal models
now for humans correlation versus
causation is like really important we
generally tend to associate correlation
with causation but correlation really
does not imply causation this is very
very much known from an early stage of
data driven analysis so for example we
can see that data show that people who
are eating to relate to their meeting so
don't hurry or you'll be late so that's
a incorrect assumption that we are
making based on just the data
our question is how can we get causes of
an event from a data set given we have
just the information on the data set
nothing else so that's the question for
causal inference
now I want to draw a difference between
causal models and machine learning
models so previously data driven
analysis has been focusing on machine
learning models where we are trying to
predict based on correlation of the data
but now for causal models we are
basically trying to look for
intervention based on the causal
relationship between data it has been
proved that data alone cannot hold
causality so we need additional
assumptions and knowledge to go and find
the causal relationships
it it is also established that there is
no true causal model it could be a
granular model or it could be a broad
level or high level of model so it could
be two variables like drug effecting the
outcome or we can just say drug is
changing your food habit that is
changing your exercise habit and that is
changing the outcome so you can go
granular or you can go back and have a
broader view but there is no true causal
model and to understand all of this
together we basically need it's like its
own mathematical formulations
so that's what causal inference research
is for
and the other thing that causal models
helps us do is to intervene in
predictive modeling or in just
Association based statistical analysis
we generally cannot intervene on one
variable and change the variable and see
what the outcome looks like so the
easiest way to find causality is an
intervention like I previously mentioned
doing a randomized control trial but
that requires proper randomization and
obviously some other other matching of
variables so we randomly force a to have
different values and we measure B
now in reality if we can do that
basically we are done we can find the
causality but in real life we cannot
always do that so it may be unethical to
give people ineffective treatment to
daily diseases or they must they might
just have a say in the treatment so it's
really important to find a way to
intervene on data and see the outcome
without actually doing that thing in the
world
now we focus on some causal questions in
healthcare research so what would we
look for if we have causal queries so
given a problem domain or research
question for example let's say covid-19
vaccine if it is in a specific
population we would look for what's the
causal mechanism so how does the causal
model look like given that we have a
data
can we see this causal machine like
we're talking about this causal model
but how do we represent that
how to contribute to causal model if we
have a causal model how can we change or
mitigate or replace some of the
variables in that causal model
fourth question is given that we know
the causal model can we estimate causal
effects sometimes it's not just feasible
to find the causal effect from the
causal model and how to apply these
ideas to real world problems so it
itself is a big issue because we can
talk about all the theories in this top
four points but when we come to a real
world scenario it becomes really messy
and complicated so how can we apply that
in real world scenarios
to summarize a significance of causal
inference in healthcare research
environment bioinformatics would be
improving the treatment outcomes it
could help us reduce bias it could help
us in information informing policy
decisions hypothesis generation and many
other features as I mentioned here now
these are really important because a
focus of at least at Oak Tree at OHSU is
doing research on bioinformatics domain
and Healthcare forecast issues so these
are really important in our problem
scenario
to summarize in actions in data driven
causal inference we basically have a
system or a word that we can look into
and then
from that word we can see the
observational data like people are
taking aspirin and they're getting rid
of headaches and that answers our
statistical queries like having aspirin
is curing most people with headaches but
that does not say anything causal
anything about it
now we can do an intervention we can do
a trial and we would get a post
intervention World which is different
from this world right in this world they
are have been people taking different
drugs now we have experimental data and
that can also causal queries like would
having a Sprint cure my headache
our goal is to use causal inference to
Traverse from observational data to
causal queries so we are basically
navigating from one word to another post
intervention world that's the goal of
data driven causal inference for
healthcare research
that concludes first part of my talk
now now I'll talk about the structural
theory of causation under caller
inference
so causal inference is already a very
broad domain of research and it contains
a lot of methodologies but there are two
standard ideal ideologies in in this
domain the first one is following Rubin
causal model which is proposed by Donald
Rubina neyman and this is based on
potential outcome framework this is very
popular this has well-known tools such
as propensity score matching invest
property trading and they are really
good in doing what they do and this has
been used for a couple of years like
like from 1970s this has been used and
these are really well established now
the new kid in town is structural theory
of causation this has been proposed by
judapple and judapple comes from not a
biostatic background or not from a
health research background but he comes
from a computer scientist bedroom and he
based this theory on probabilistic
graphical models
tools used under structural theory of
position is causal graphical models and
do calculus which is a new mathematical
formulation to do all of this
now why would I should choose a
structural theory of position because
this is a computational algorithmic
approach this helps us use graphical
models which is very easy to visualize
and it's helpful in understanding the
different ongoing relationships it helps
us it actually gives us two calculus
which is a new mathematics that we can
do to find causation and this is very
much big data difference so the more
data we have the more computational
power we have we can use the structural
theory of causation more
so that's what we choose for causal
inference research in our our
applications
to give you a quick overview under
structural theory of causation the
fundamental component is structural
causal models this is basically model M
which is a photopol uvf and pu u and v
are just variables if are the functions
which connect U to V and P U is the
probability distribution of all the
variables
my apologies just just a second
all right I stopped my Mac from going to
sleep
okay so this is structure causal model
which has four components of it and this
can be easily seen in this causal graphs
like smoking causing lung cancer so X
arrows to Y so X is triggering some
change in y
this can be seen with confounder
variables as well like lifestyle having
impact on both smoking and lung cancer
and it can also be shown with the
mediator like live straight causing both
and tar in lungs kind of mediator
between smoking and lung cancer now when
we use these words confounder mediator
and other variables previously we used
to do it in a text-based scenario but
right now with structural causal models
it's really easy to visualize it in a
graph and it's really easy to understand
or explain to other people
it helps us do intervention like we we
can now intervene using Duke helpless so
the notation to do intervention is like
probability of Y conditional on do X so
we are basically manipulating the
variable X to see the change in y
this is very much different from
conditioning because in probability
conditioning means probability of Y
condition on X which is basically
condition on variable X and C the
outcome y but in manipulation or do
intervention we actually change the
value of x set it to some value and see
how the outcome changes based on that so
it's very much equivalent to removing
this arrow and setting this value of
smoking ax2 it's kind of like saying if
we set all population to do smoking or
not to do smoking so it's not really
possible but it's kind of a simulation
of a real world scenario
going back to that previous example that
on the drug trial we can simply solve
those that symptom symptoms Paradox
using ducal plus now
if we use this causal graph
if we look at the general effect it
would be conditional probability between
these two which is negative 0.5 so it it
would like if we combine all those data
it seems like the drug is not really
good because it's 78 percent minus 83
percent so basically five percent of
difference
but if we now use the structural theory
of causation and we use the Google Plus
we solve for all the equations and we
end up with 10 Improvement so basically
we are saying
if it is good in men and if it is good
in women then it doesn't matter what the
gender of the person is it is overall
beneficial to that population Group
which is 10 percent so that's the
summary from from this Google class
equation and symptoms products and other
paradoxes can be easily solved using
these notations and this is also really
good to find all the biases that comes
from different experimental studies like
confirming bias where some variables
controlling two other variables or
selection bars where we are selecting on
a specific population subgroup and
creating a fake association between
these two variables
there are some other complicated biases
like embass where we are
conditioning on the common outcome of
causes for both treatment and outcome so
it also creates a fake Association going
from low education to solvency during
Parenthood and then this way around so
we can all adjust accordingly using
these notations
one of the key component of structural
theory of causation is the ladder of
causation
which is how we do and how we see the
world and how we use data related to it
so this is in our world because we are
now have more available big data and we
have been using machine learning AI
methods for a long time and now it's
time to look for causal inference so in
this ladder in the Bottom Rung we are
basically looking at the data we are
looking at Association so we are looking
at how one object is associated with
another if just one probability changes
so for example we can say like Shoppers
who buy toothpaste are more likely to
buy dental floss so we are just
conditioning on two variables
this gives us Insight but not much but
what we want to do is basically do on
the data so we want to intervene we want
to change specific variables and see how
it changes the outcome on on top of that
now
intervention is also really good but
hypothetically or in real world we want
to do the counterfectual thing where we
have data on past event and based on
that past event we want to imagine how
it changes the new event like
given doubling the price of toothpaste
has no impact on floss sales if we had
given a 50 cell toothpaste what would be
the probability that the purchasing
would change so we know that previously
we doubled the toothpaste price and the
floss sales did not change now if we
give a 50 sale what would happen based
on this data and the causal information
in this world or in this counterfecture
scenario we basically need information
from both Association and intervention
and causal model so that's a really high
level thing that we are trying to hope
for but that's kind of the ladder of
causation and that's what we want to
climb using data and information that we
have
causal structural learning algorithms
are an outcome of the structural theory
of causation where we can iterate
through data look at the conditional
probability distribution and based on
some assumptions we can learn the causal
structure there are various causal
structure learning algorithms such as PC
algorithm FC algorithm which is
constraint based method and there are
some other methods as well and these are
really good in finding a causal
structure just from the data itself
application of causal structure learning
algorithm this is a really important
part of today's talk and as well as the
research join and people have been
trying to use these methodology in
different research part like for this
study City honeycomb being identified a
progressive February phenotype and it
has this really complex causal structure
and this is just an example of
healthcare research but this this has
been also used in like environmental
science like modeling air pollution and
climate where the causal graph looks
like this and the more data you have the
more variables you have the causal graph
gets starts to get really messy
now I will go into my two applied works
that we have been doing for last few
years in causal inference my previous
theoretical Works involved Hazard Rishi
estimation for absorption data using
causal inference we also tried to do
causal model estimation from data and
background knowledge and we propose the
new causal knowledge hierarchy we are
also trying to
portray pragmatic clinical trials which
is a different version of trial rather
than randomized trials using structural
causal models in application part we
have worked on efficacy estimation of
antipsychotic drugs for delirium
patients and causal modeling for liberal
versus conservative oxygen therapy in
ICU which
we will talk about in in the next part
of this talk we have we are also working
on a tutorial to build on causal
fairness analysis which is already
presented by one of our interns last
week
so the first study that we did is
causalist Discovery on the effect of
antipsychotic drugs on daily Ambitions
in the ICU
what is the research problem in this
scenario so delirium is a syndrome of
disturbance of Consciousness with
reducibility focus and it has been found
in 80 of cases in the ICU and this is
associated longer Hospital stay and
increased mortality now the treatment of
delirium is generally done with
different antipsychotic drugs like hello
parietal ziprasidon or olanzapine
we are using these antipsychotic drugs
but there has been controversies in
which drug is more effective in treating
delirium we exactly do not know it yet
and there has been multiple randomized
control trials done on this part now our
cities are trying to look for which drug
is more effective but our cities are
obviously very expensive in terms of
time money and share of resource and the
studies did not have any agreement in
between their outcomes so what we're
trying to do here is use large EHR data
set
um we want to do an obsercial study and
try to simulate an RCT from there using
causal inference or structural theory of
causation
the problem statement that we are going
for was can we explore existing large
operational Healthcare data for finding
the efficacy of antipsychotics in the
treatment of delirium
our approach involved using a large EHR
data set which is mimic 3. this mimic 3
is a large electronic Healthcare record
data set it has around 53 000 patient
information with 40K patient information
over 12 years
and some of you already have explored
this mimic three data this is a really
resourceful thing for
um eh researchers
what we did is we started with defining
a Target trial so we defined trial that
we are trying to mimic using this data
set
we extracted delirium patients based on
ICD-9 primarily based on ICD-9 code
293.0 but there have been some other
factors as well we extracted related
covariates after that we did three times
three types of analysis which is
exploratory analysis then machine
learning driven analysis which is the
traditional approach of predicting the
outcome and finally we look for causal
analysis like can we generate the causal
structure from this data and can we find
the causal effect from it
so the general pipeline looks kind of
like this um
we started with a problem statement the
reason I'm going through this pipeline
is that this is basically useful in
other similar studies where we want to
find the causal effect from our social
data so we start with the problem
statement which is is celebrated better
in treatment daily I mean the ICU
compared to other antipsychic graphs or
even no drugs
we defined a Target trial that helped us
Define all the relevant features we
extract 11 data from the EHR
then we started the exploratory analysis
after that we do the predictive modeling
or the causal modeling which has
multiple steps involved in it
and it would give us a predictive
knowledge the causal factors the causal
effect and hopefully cause
counterfactual from those data
so
in this left side this is a randomized
control trial based on delirium
patient's ICU but what we are trying to
do is like extract this data have this
observation study and try to simulate
that like emulated RCT for from there
now we started with defining the target
trial which contains basically the Pico
like the population intervention control
outcome along with some kind of time
analysis plan and causal contrast
um we started with defining what was the
eligibility criteria which is like ICU
admitted adult patient has to be more
than 18 years they have been diagnosed
with delirium and some other factors
three treatment strategies were defined
patient groups who were prescribed more
antipsychotic drugs who were described
prescribed hello paridle and who would
prescribe other anti-secretings than
hello Bridal
and then again we Define the follow-up
period we Define the outcome which is
death timeline whether the person died
in hospitals or died within 90 days 30
days or a year
and our secondary outcomes were the
treatment timeline which is length of
stay in the hospital and length of
mechanical meditation in the ICU
following that we mined the data from
the EHR Mimi 3 we looked at the patient
tables hospital admission tables and IC
State details these are the specific
table name in this in this mimic 3
database if you are interested to like
reuse it for a later research purpose we
created the base data set from there
after that we used other tables to find
the disease and drug information and
finally we ended up with health status
data like what is the sofa score what is
the aps-3 score or the wind durations in
this data set
eventually combining all this together
we ended up with a mimic delirium data
set which is a population set of six
around 600 patients
um this has 1600 rows and 28 variables
which is mentioned here these are all
possible related covariates with
treatment as the drug group and the
outcomes are death in hospital or death
timeline length of Stanley timing
mechanical ventilation
we started with some exploratory
analysis how the data set looks like I
will not go into details of all this
because these are very standard um but
this kind of shows like the hello pedal
group the other drugs and no drugs group
how the population is defined to give a
quick overview we have more patients in
the age group of 65 to 85 because
delirium occurs more as the patient is
more aged and the length of stay is
generally on the lower side but it it
gradually tapers off with number of days
and we also looked at the related
diseases that the patients has
based on three drug groups we found that
our mean length of stay and max length
of stays higher for patients in the
fallopital drug Group which is just
observational information not a really
statistically composed information when
multiple antipsychotic drug is given
hellopetal is generally included in most
cases because this is the most popular
drug of choice and it has a higher death
rate
since it has been given in maturity
cases so this is just an observational
information from this data set
we started with some predictive analysis
where we tried to run eight machine
learning models and see how it performs
on the data set this is just this just
gives us an overview how the data set
looks like on how that address it
performs we were looking at death in
hospital as primary outcome for this
purpose and it feels like the random
Forest classifier gave the highest value
which has the highest F1 score along
with accuracy precision recall and it
also has the higher Eleanor curve
decision tree and XD bus also had better
metrics because these are all tree base
classifier and also outside of previous
classifier the logic aggregation
performed really well so the two good
thing the loss distribution always works
well so that's what we found here
finally when we start with the causal
modeling part of it um we basically look
at causal structure learning so we used
eight structural learning algorithms and
we ran these through all the data and we
found eight structure learning causal
structures merged them together to find
this causal structure now this is a
little bit hard to see so that's why I
decided to zoom in on one part of it so
like this is the drug Group which is the
treatment it has a causal impact on the
death in hospital and there are other
variables like sofa score or drug time
length connected with this so this is a
complex causal graph and that kind of
gives insight to the researchers how the
variables interact intelligent patients
in the ICU
our last part involves causal
identification so we try to look into
the causal effect based on probabilistic
equations so what is the probability of
death in hospital if we do or if we
physically manipulate the drug group
so we did this for all four outcomes
which is death in hospital death
timeline length of stays and timing
mechanical ventilation it gave us
different equations and using those
equations and the data that we have we
found the average causal effect or even
statement effect on the drug group on
different outcomes
quick give a quick overview generally
there is no difference in death in
hospital like 0.03.02 there is no
difference but in length of stay
seems like Hello Operator or other drug
did better than any other like not
giving any kind of drug so it's better
than the other one and the effect is
shown in in graphically here in the
bottom part
so to summarize this study um our
observation study basically created a
prospective data code which is mimic
delirium which would be reusable in
further delirium related research the
data properties for mimic lithium
provided insights into patient
demographic the machine learning driven
analysis shows the strength of the
prediction algorithm the causal analysis
found that there is no significant
impact of ruptures in depth in hospital
no significant impact of antipsychotic
choice is length of stay and haloperol
did much better than other drugs or no
drugs in affecting the time mechanical
ventilation
now obviously this is an observational
study transformed in red and verse
control trial using causal effects
methodology so there has been lots of
assumptions included uh one assumption
is that the Deliverance patients in the
ICU is representative of General delium
demography because it occurs mostly in
ICU
we have not been using any kind of
background knowledge in building this
causal structure because there was lots
of controversy in research results so we
did not use it at all
now this would change in our next
research problem but for now we did not
use anything here our limitation was we
did not have an access to experienced
physician actively working in the ICU
and our future work involves
collaboration with icus or explore
additional features like additional
procedures such as survival analysis or
Cox regression analysis and that
concluded this study that we did this is
currently under review at scientific
reports at nature and we are hoping
really hoping for some good feedback
from the reviewers and hopefully we can
publish it there
the last research study that I will
present is structural causal model with
expert augmented con augmented knowledge
to estimate the effect of oxygen therapy
on mortality in the ICU this is a study
that is very similar in structure but it
it involves the involves background
knowledge in incorporating the causal
structure and this has been already
published in AI in medicine from LCBL
which is a very high impact
journal in our computer science research
field
so what what is the problem in this
scenario
um
sorry so oxygen therapy is very much
given in critical ill patients um
approximately two to three billion
patients in the U.S receive invasive
mechanical ventilation in ICU and this
is associated with morbidity and
mortality it is really vital to maintain
safe levels of oxygenation using spo2 or
oxygen saturation because this is really
helpful in uh like maintaining a safe
level of tissue oxygenation and
renewed interest as new service new
evidence suggests that not all patients
May benefit from the same oxidation
study strategy
so the current practice and
recommendation for oxygenation is that
they are not based on strong evidence
they are primarily based on normal
physiological value in healthy adults
like the situation at 90 degree or O2
sat is 95 to 97 or the other values now
this this approach varies from like less
than 90 percent to 94 to 98 percent so
one is a liberal approach one is a
conservative approach the liberal
approach to oxygen therapy is now being
challenged due to increasing recognition
of the potential harm of excessive fio2
in the form of hyperoxoma and tissue
hyperxia so this controversy like
whether should we use the liberal
oxidation therapy or the conservative
one in treating ICU patients that's the
question that we are looking for so can
we investigate the effect of
conservative versus liberal oxidation
studies on mortality and number of
Veterinary days among patients in the
icos receiving imv
so in this study what we changed is like
we did three things in parallel we
followed a pilot RCT which is a
published article they did they did and
randomized control trial on this case so
that's a pilot study because they
included on a very small number of
population we tried to
sorry we tried to do do that along with
uh we also followed correlation based
absorption study which is just using the
data set and then we also used an ACM
based virtual randomized control trial
our source data set was again mimic 3
and we defined the target trial and did
the same similar kind of analysis in
this part as well
so
just to reiterate through the same thing
we Define the target trial
what was the eligibility what were the
treatment strategies the treatment
strategy was conservative oxidation
strategy with 88 to 95 percent or
liberal oxygen therapy which which has
oxidation saturation equal to 97 96
percent or more
uh our outcome was 90-day mortality and
the follow-up periods were the the
timeline they were in the ICU
now
you can see that
you can see that on the left this is the
pilot RCT that they did where they
looked at patient greater than 18 years
who received IMB for less than 24 hours
and continued more than 24 hours and
they only ended up at publishing like 50
and 52 which is a general case for a
pilot randomized computer trial in our
case we screened through 60 000 patients
and eventually we ended up with around
3000 3800 liberal patient and
conservative 250. so there was already a
little bit biased throughout the liberal
strategy but that's what we ended up
with
in this case what was different we tried
to encode expertology in cosmograph and
how did we do that we we tried to reduce
the controversial causal ages we
iterated through different literatures
and see how or what they suggested like
from age to trauma there was a change
orientation based on domain expert from
this literature so similar I just show a
part of it but there is a big list of
different literatures that we look went
through and used that information in a
loop in this generated causal structure
along this algorithm
this resulted us in a new data set which
is for oxygen therapy and again you can
see different variable demographics this
this part is for the simulated
randomized control trial and this is the
original oxygen therapy RCT that they
did we kind of show Apple to Apple
comparison so how it looks compared to
an actual study that has been done on
this part
um we found this causal structure
learning part where we ended up with
this causal structure where you can see
that this is the oxygen level which has
an impact on the death along with some
other variables that has been found in
the IC data set and this is again a
really complex causal information and we
need to go through all of this to find a
really true causal effect
so for causal identification we we
iterate it to different equations uh
finally this is just one version of it
where we are looking at the probability
of death
in hospital conditional on the Apes
score and the sofa score and when we
change the oxidation level
so this is how we iterate it through the
equation these are different variables
and finally we ended up with these
equations now there are different causal
identified estimates that we report in
the paper but for now I'm just going
through this one
eventually we ended up with this result
where we can see that what is the
probability of death condition just
oxidation nothing has been changed or
intervened then we look at the very
probability of death do on oxygenation
same thing goes for this and we report
the observation data also the virtual
rcd and it showed us in general that
liberal has less mean values compared to
conservative values what it means is
that
we studied the causal effect of liberal
versus conservative oxidation therapy in
4000 mechanical ventilatory patients or
90-day mortality we saw that from the
previous table that an advantage of
level strategy over uh conservative one
by adjusting on age so far Apes score
now this is inconsistent with previous
rcgs that has been found so we still
reported it because this might shade
some information on on the literature
and the weird City the virtual render
voice control that we did found that
given the stability of illness based on
physiological School the liberal
approach lowers the mortality expression
which is kindness which is consistent
with the other R cities that has been
done
again it included lots of assumptions
the first one is causal faithfulness uh
the aestheticity like the causal graph
does not create a cycle and gaussian
distribution of data our limitation was
again we had little access to
experienced physician actively working
the ICU and we did not consider any
change in oxidation study due to change
in patient health
and our future work involves temporal
causal Discovery algorithm because
there's lots of lots of temporal
component in this in this research model
so again this has been already published
in artificial intelligence in medicine
and you can go online and check this
work if if you look this is interesting
so to summarize an inconclusion
um
what we wanted to convey is like causal
inference is a great new tool to
untangle this causal relationships from
observational Healthcare data and this
is what we have been promoting for last
couple of years that we want to build
some kind of tool that Physicians or
researchers or clinicians can really use
without going into all the details
Nativity details of the theoretical part
but we want to really establish this as
a framework that people can easily go
into and use and visualize their
information through some kind of
Knowledge Graph
because it for this kind of research
work would be having a basic on computer
science and AIML along with lots of
information from biostatistics and lots
of clinical research domain so it's
really hard to do by one's personal self
rather than it takes a team effort to
conduct research on this one
this strength of
causal inference or structural Theory
causation would be in general better
understanding of the physical world it
reduces our cost energy in terms of
doing different trials every time it's
very much applicable in healthcare
research and obviously the biostatical
methods are really good and really
important in this part but this gives us
a little bit more information on top of
all those methods so we are not saying
that ignore all those methods we are
saying that use these tools along with
all the other biostatical biostatistical
methods
obviously it has some own weaknesses it
has like its own sets of challenges
there's lots of missing data and it
includes a lot of assumptions because
it's really hard to go from data to some
kind of causal inference and this
inference is just as good as the data if
the data is skewed or it is biased it's
really hard to do all this research work
and it has a really great potential in
healthcare research because it can
create new hypotheses or new uh shades
of new light in existing problem domains
and we I introduce talk with few open
research problems which is um
under causal inference there are
different structure learning algorithms
which we are continuously looking for
how we can find out new causal inference
based structure learning algorithms we
still don't know how to Ensemble all the
outputs of different learning algorithms
we are we have been coming up new or
altered assumptions and it's really hard
to extract proper data from Obsession
data as well because there's always this
chance of missing out some important
variables and application is specific
branches are challenges by itself
because the same information does not
translate from Finance or economics to
just Healthcare research because they
work in different different way
underlying so it's these are all open
research problems under structural
theory of causation
so that kind of concludes my talk um
these are some of the reference that we
used and most of the references can be
found in our published papers
and for those of you who missed the
first part of it my name is I go by
ridhi I'm currently an informatics
postdoctoral researcher at Oak Tree OHSU
I've been working with Dr Mohammad who
is a director co-director at Oak Tree my
background is I completed my page and
Masters and competitions for Market
University and my research Focus lies in
data driven causal inference causal
exploration along with bioinformatics
and broader data science I am really
happy to give this talk today and I am
really excited to share some of my
research works that we have been doing
the last couple of years with you all
thank you for listening thank you all
for listening and if you have any
question you can ask that is now thank
you
hi I have a quick question my name is Q
um
in the second study that you presented
uh did
the data factor in
um like how bad the lung disease was for
the ICU patients because I'm sure
that affects the oxygenation of the body
in clinical settings we have like
oxygenation index or PF ratio
so that's my question
um
hello yeah
so yeah we considered the lung
lung cases as well it has been
Incorporated I think in some of the sofa
and af3 school as well as probably some
kind of COPD so we we believe we did
that if not directly it has been
included in the overall health scores
such as the sofa
similar question a little more
conceptual picture in terms of all of
these variables
or how is it are you doing Eda to figure
out which ones might contribute is there
is it based on clinical expertise
like how do you arrive at kind of this
list of variables to put into these
models
well that is actually really good
question because this has been puzzling
us for a long long time so what we do is
like based on
some problem statement and the keywords
we collect a lot of publication so this
is one approach when we do not take help
from physicians in the ICU but when we
do have access to Physicians or expert
researchers then we do it differently
but for now what we did is go through
published literatures like we collect
like 10 or 15 of literatures and look at
what variables they considered so we
create a superset of all of them we look
for those variables in the mimic 3 data
set like how much information can we
collect from there
does that
answer your question
it does I kind of Wonder I mean yes a
lot of these variables are what you
would see in published literature and
critical care outcomes ventilation Etc
but
to some extent there's I mean there's
variables you aren't that maybe aren't
being considered and I wonder how to use
these methods or different methods to
kind of tease out if there's some
confounders there's some mediators that
aren't as common but are buried in these
data sets if there is so much data in
these data sets that's underutilized
eventually
yes just like any other studies like
experimental studies there is always a
risk of unobserved on major concerning
variables of some kind of mediators but
we try to mitigate that by including
lots of variables because somehow this
could be working as an instrumental
variable or this could be presented some
by some other variables so we try to
involve as much information as we can
but obviously there is always this risk
of missing out on some like important
information that we just did not
consider before
thank you there's also a few questions
in the chat that um I would like to make
sure are addressed
um so Francis asked um
if you did not rely on any background
knowledge in the delirium study how did
you know what covariates to include in
the model after their relationships in
the SCM
oh okay yeah that's a good question um I
actually was not probably clear on that
part so we by talking about background
knowledge we were talking about any
causal age from variable a to variable B
we obviously included information from
Publications that I just mentioned so we
decided on the variables like it comes
from different Publications but we did
not involve any causal age or variable a
triggering variable B from the
literature
okay thank you
um and then Nicole is asking if there's
any resources you would recommend for
intro to do calculus I kind of had the
same question as well
um I don't know if you could if you have
any that you could pull and put in the
chat or send Nicole on an email
with some some references
yeah the main thing that I would
recommend is like that's a very short
book causal inference a primer which is
by Judah Pearl
but the issue with that is that is very
much Theory heavy but it doesn't happen
a lot about how to apply to healthcare
research that so that's what
one component of our research interest
is that try to translate all this for a
healthcare research domain so that we
see the theories alongside some kind of
application on how it looks but causal
influencer primer would be a good
suggestion I I can send you an email
after this talk
okay great thank you
um and then uh Nate Evans asks
um do causal models assume linearity of
variables and are there versions of this
causal inference appropriate to cyclic
graphs
um so basically it's two questions right
so first one is like yeah there's two
questions does it assume like linearity
um it does in some some of the causal
structural learning algorithms but
sometimes it does not so there are
different
versions of causal structure learning
let me just quickly go there
yeah this one here so um
I I did not mention one of the
algorithms here which is very popular uh
which is lingam so that con that assumes
a linear non-gaussian modeling I guess
some kind of so in that case it kind of
assumes linearity but for some of these
it it does not assume that so there are
different versions of it and this is
also an open research problem how do we
Ensemble results from
a causal structure learning algorithm
that assumes different things from the
other ones so some assumes linearity sum
does not how do you merge all this
information together so that's
the first part and the second part I
assume is like if if there is anything
for cyclic causal graphs right
um
yes
I don't think there has been any work on
cyclic causal graphs because
when there are cyclic components it kind
of translate to a temporal part like
something is changing the other thing
and in the next time frame that is
creating a new outcome so I don't see
anything that works with cyclic causal
graphs but I would love to look more
into this part like if there has been
any new development here
thank you and Nate thanks you as well
um does anybody have more uh any more
questions
online or in the room
okay
um if there's no more questions
um I'd like to thank the speaker again
[Applause]